greetings [ __ ] uncle Joey a
little tropical backdrop behind me to
put you at ease how are you
it's April 14th I gotta get my medical
marijuana license today and I go for a
meeting let me taste something it's been
a long week
been a long THC and infused week I could
feel it now I'm not to go to jujitsu
just to sweat out part of this THC and
he's [ __ ] Hitler edibles we've been
eating lately but [ __ ] it sometimes you
gotta go deep you understand me
sometimes you gotta [ __ ] go deeper
than deep like the black mamba did last
night anyway it's a beautiful day to be
alive
you're [ __ ] alive and while you're
kicking you're healthy and if you're not
healthy you're on your way to get out
the understand me yeah I woke up with a
[ __ ] THC hangover I had two cups of
coffee a few jumping jacks few push-ups
I took a shower I did a [ __ ] almond
milk smoothie I did I just couldn't
shake it
understand me a little mile off
being on me
we've got to do what you got a different
here you've gotta do what you gotta do
sometimes you gotta take a bullet for
the team
you're my family you know I'm saying how
am I gonna you know for most people I
don't know what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you gotta get up you gotta get out
there
you gotta get up you gotta get out there
[ __ ]
you gotta smoke some really eat some
fruit to a few jumping jacks and that's
it everything [ __ ] works I understand
it's time to smoke another bowl that's
boat number two only have you smoked a
lake on something it's 817 the morning
I'm already alive and [ __ ] kicking
I've grown an excerpt already made phone
calls I've humiliated people have
bothered people I woke up the flying Jew
you know how we do it Doug never of
[ __ ] dull moment if you stop
moving you won't feel a breeze you
always gotta feel the breeze brother
that's how you know you're making it's
not gonna happen
but time to time you gotta take a little
break and this is where you come in we
get together as a family we smoke a bowl
we put our thoughts together and then we
move on in this family that [ __ ]
that's it man that's all I can give you
yeah I'm saying you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart I think
this is the most important time about
there is a family some people make it
dinner for us it's the morning we get
our thoughts out there we smoked a
couple boots roots we crack a [ __ ]
joke or two and we get the [ __ ] most
importantly you get to see yourself from
a different perspective I'm not yelling
I'm not screaming it's just a beautiful
day clouds are out I don't give a [ __ ] I
got a mission to do just like you you
got a mission to heaven good little girl
and they yelling and screaming but he
had them bounce I'm gonna walk in the
school then we're taking my wife to
breakfast then I got a 10:00 a.m.
[ __ ] meeting and I go to jujitsu and
then I'm gonna write write write write
write write write write write and then
I'm gonna do a spot at the store at 11
o'clock and then next week I'm gonna
announce well I'm gonna shoot two
[ __ ] special you understand we got a
special we're gonna shoot it and we got
the city will not be [ __ ] announcing
and we're ready to go [ __ ]
if you don't do this with me in the
morning you're not gonna do anything
because this is it easy as it gets and I
know you got weed even if it sucks what
happened
what he didn't do oh yeah say they're
waving silent or you see getting
addicted when I thought I'd be like you
gotta put your batteries in today cuz
they ain't giving away dick today so
everybody's gonna it's a pocket thinking
about Friday you gotta go up there and
work a little [ __ ] on it I smoked a
little more dope so you get different
[ __ ] brain waves you can you attack
the wallet and half the D this is yours
you understand me but whether you gave
me this or not till it's all about you
and how you feel and your connection cut
a [ __ ] beautiful orange understand me
my connection is I smoked at this
[ __ ] grass and pops up I'm gonna lie
to you what connection we should we
smoked another book it's Thursday and
with family what the [ __ ] what else you
don't do we attack I'm gonna send you
out there amongst the [ __ ] wolves
like the biggest [ __ ] wolf understand
me
[ __ ] these [ __ ] sheep he [ __ ]
well then I yeah just fill up another
bowl here cuz we're family you know this
is it
what does this begin the more they wanna
the [ __ ] newscasters who does this
your school teachers your uncle [ __ ]
Joey that's who does this concept
you watch the podcast last night you
gotta breathe I've been doing the
exercise and a few exercises this
morning she's right man do some [ __ ]
weight I gotta get the diaphragm moving
these are little things we learnt don't
wait to get it be a fat [ __ ] like me in
your forties you could start today raft
we smoked this batch of [ __ ] dust is
my best water today when I get together
with you people on periscope we smoked a
little joy no drama no [ __ ] no not
just us man you know I wouldn't do this
for any else to do this with you guys
cuz you appreciate man I appreciate your
visible someone but that's it
we had a good wave into some podcast
look back Monday we're back Wednesday
then I'm a [ __ ] Buffalo [ __ ]
Africa will be there a lot of weed you
know we doing so please have a great
debt man walk there and give that
[ __ ] day hell when you go home
at night you notice it tango you know
what I didn't [ __ ] do much to him at
least I [ __ ] tried I [ __ ] song
like a [ __ ]
I put the pieces together sometimes the
pieces don't go together next week I'll
be three weeks from now but at least you
built the [ __ ] foundation
well more possibly gotta get the [ __ ]
out you taped there in the morning
people to put this on rehab who the
[ __ ] most don't believe the more we do
that's who packs sucker and they were
[ __ ] say what you gotta say
all right dolly I love you [ __ ]
stay black have a great day I love you
[ __ ]
my mother day away you understand me you
don't go down for nobody you don't give
up you don't [ __ ] it they can't win even
if you [ __ ] give up you understand me
that's the attitude today either they're
gonna suck your dick pulling gonna suck
your dick that's it nice and easy no
money back guarantee this is to the
[ __ ] and stay black I love you
[ __ ]